Marvel isn't just telling a story in
their films they're creating a whole
universe so if a character makes even
the smallest cameo in a movie chances
are there's a lot more to them than
we're seeing on screen here's a spoiler
filled look at some characters and thor
ragnarok with more meaning than you
might have realized Valkyrie movie fans
around the world were thrilled when they
learned that the Hulk would be teaming
up with the god of thunder and thor
ragnarok
but comic book fans were even more
excited to see the whole team up with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe a--'s
newest super heroine Valkyrie
that's because Hulk and Valkyrie were
friends and teammates for years in the
pages of the classic Marvel series the
defenders which also featured Doctor
Strange and the Submariner while the
defenders name has been poached by
marbles TV division seeing Valkyrie Hulk
and Doctor Strange in the same movie
keeps the dream of a big screen
defenders reunion alive and further
opens the door for the eventual
appearance of Namor in the MCU
Grandmaster known across the galaxies as
the Grandmaster and we gassed is more
than just a guy who loves games and
bloodsport he's also one of the elders
of the universe which in Marvel Comics
is a group of immortal beings of immense
power who are traditionally the
guardians of the Infinity stones like
his fellow elder the collector who was
played by Benicio del Toro and guardians
of the galaxy the Grandmaster is likely
to make another appearance when Thanos
finally rears his head in Avengers
infinity war scourge the executioner
hellas minions scourge the executioner
has a long and curious history in the
comics a longtime villain an adversary
to Thor scourge eventually redeemed
himself in an epic storyline where he
held off the armies of Hell armed with a
pair of machine guns in order to save
Thor and a group of innocent mortals
fleeing from hella that part made it
into the film but for most of his
existence
it wasn't hella that scourge was
associated with but rather his one true
love the immortal Asgardian sorceress
known as The Enchantress both an enemy
and occasional ally of Thor The
Enchantress is arguably the most
important character from Thor comics who
hasn't yet appeared in the MCU the
appearance of scourge and thor ragnarok
suggests that might
on the verge of finally changing coorg
the rock-like korg belongs to a species
that has actually been teased twice
before in the MCU first and Thor the
dark world and then again in a quick
Easter egg in guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 and the character contains another
secret as the CGI created gladiator was
played by thor ragnarok director Taika
Waititi himself but the real easter egg
behind Korg is a deep cut from the very
dawn of Marvel Comics he's part of the
alien race originally known as the stone
men from Saturn who Thor fought in his
very first comic book appearance in 1962
s journey into mystery number 83 in fact
in the comics Korg himself is one of the
very a lean invaders Thor battled in his
origin story how cool is that
miik poor little meek is played purely
for comic relief in thor ragnarok but in
the comics he's a much darker figure a
lot of the plot of thor ragnarok is
borrowed from the planet hulk comic book
story in which hope leads a band of
fellow gladiators and the planets a car
in a revolution hulk then becomes ruler
of the planet which is where things take
a sinister turn for meek unsatisfied to
the new piece Hulk is ushered in meek is
complicit in a plot that leads to the
death of Hulk's wife and child
sending Hulk on a vengeful rampage
across the galaxy it's only later that
Hulk discovers the base treachery of his
supposed friend he doesn't seem so cute
and goofy now does he topaz the Grand
Master's right-hand woman originally
wasn't even a Marvel character at all
instead she was created at Malibu comics
as Queen topaz the ruler of a race of
alien Amazons eventually she ended up as
a superhero on earth after Marvel bought
Malibu and folded some of its characters
into the Marvel Universe she was
summoned by the Grandmaster to be a pawn
in a contest with Loki losing a fight
against crystal and black widow of the
Avengers topaz is the first Malibu
character to make it into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe opening the door for
characters like hardcase firearm and
prime to potentially make the jump to
the big screen as well beta ray bill
eagle-eyed observers may have noticed
that one of the busts adorning the
outside of grandmasters Tower is none
other than beta ray bill himself who's
that
ask well you know that inscription on
Thor's hammer that says whoever is
worthy can lift the hammer and gain the
power of Thor in the comics beta ray
bill shocked thorne fans alike by
proving himself worthy and lifting the
hammer he became as powerful as Thor
himself and earned the Thunder gods
trust as the sworn brother from another
alien mother beta ray bill has been a
fan favourite ever since he first
debuted in the early 80s so the fact
that the film acknowledge his existence
is enough to send hardcore Thor fans
over the moon it means that somewhere
out there in the MCU beta ray bill
exists now it's just a matter of
actually putting him into a movie
instead of just a statue of his head
are you listening marvel thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]